une vaste étude qui a suivi pendant une
trentaine d'années 200000 jumeaux
scandinave a permis à des chercheurs de
l'université harvard et university
health in qui en finlande d'évaluer le
rôle de l'hérédité pour plus d'une
vingtaine de cancer différents
on sent michel on soit en cellule car
c'est vraiment intéressant ces chiffres
mais disons d'abord que c'est pas tout à
fait inédit de se servir de jumeaux pour
tenter de savoir quelle est l'équité en
termes maladie vous avez tout à fait
raison ou depuis plus d'une cinquantaine
d'années on étudie les jumeaux en
médecine pour toutes sortes de choses
c'est là il faut intéressante parce
qu'on aura gardé beaucoup de cancers on
a le regard des 23 et sur 200 milles mon
dieu c'est une énorme cohorte entre
finalement 1943 et l'an 2010 la snrt 60
ans de naissance et de mort de jumeaux
dans cet immense cohorte la voyons les
rouergats regardons ces résultats-là
donc de façon générale c'était unique de
façon globale l'hérédité responsable de
33 % des cancers
le plus virulent sur le plan est édité à
c'est le mélanome 58% les au cancer de
peau 43% ensuite la prostate 57 les
ovaires 39 et le ce1 27 et comment
est-ce qu'on a procédé parce qu'on s'est
bien sûr qu'il ya deux types de jumeaux
identiques ou fraternelle exact donc on
n'a pas pris de chance on avait 2 12
immense cohorte fraternelle est
identique alors identiques si un seul
oeuf fraternelle ces deux jeux alors un
seul oeuf on est et on se doutait qu'on
était pour avoir des chiffres beaucoup
plus fort sur le plan statistique et
c'est ça que l'on a obtenue
naturellement quand on a deux yeux c'est
un peu comme frère et sao vous et moi ou
qui ont des frais ça donc c'est un peu
plus digne alors regardons effectivement
ce que ça a donné
donc les chances que l'on ait le même
cancer mais ses 38% des jumeaux
identiques qui ont eu le même cancer il
26% des jumeaux fraternels
ça laisse quand même beaucoup de gens
qui ont eu des jumeaux toutes sortes de
cancers alors alors les frères et ça
offrait à frère avait des cancers
différents ce qui veut dire que dans les
lignées familiales c'est pas
monolithique on l'a souvent différents
cancers dans la même famille qui courent
alors comment tout ça s'applique pour
des gens comme nous a pas la majorité
les gens ne sont pas les jumeaux c'est
plus en consultation génétique en fait
que sarah voir beaucoup d'application si
par exemple un homme une femme vient de
voir un médecin
et là on découvre que dans leurs
familles respectives ya beaucoup de
mélanome mais là on va probablement dire
voilà là soit près de 60% 60%
vous risquez d'avoir un enfant qui va
voir un mélanome donc c'est
véritablement pour aider les médecins à
faire la consultation génétique beaucoup
plus fine et beaucoup plus éclairés donc
là on a vraiment une preuve qu'elle est
dit et joue un rôle très l'absolu main
merci beaucoup michel merci beaucoup de
céline